i love this man's work i'm thrilled that
he's back here on the show
he was on as part of his uh emmy
award-winning work
in modern family now in season two uh
of duncanville the animated comedy on
fox that premiered past this past
weekend with two episodes
the man who plays uh duncan's father in
this
a uh let me get this right classic rock
obsessed plumber
ty burrell back here on the rich island
show how are you ty
hi rich i i am great if for no other
reason than to listen to ed o'neill
talks for
a few minutes yeah we just we just we
just played that and i i i
give me your give me your give me your
best at o'neill's story do you have one
ty you got it you got one
oh my gosh please uh you know
ed so ed basically taught us
how to act on television even though
some of us
had thought we kind of knew what we were
doing ed
ed really showed us the tricks of the
trade and by the tricks of the trade i
mean
how to do the absolute least
uh give the absolute least amount of
physical effort possible and still
get through your day and
so ed we actually wrote this sort of
like it's a fake book
about all of ed's wisdom but
ed is so the perfect place
for to do any scene is in a car
for ed because you get you're sitting
down
you don't have to move there's no
blocking
and uh you don't have to wear pants
so so
when you're talking about a scene with
you know
the writers or the director or whatever
ed would always say
i mean you know with you know winking at
us like
is there any reason that this scene
can't be in a car
[Laughter]
oh my god there's no obvious reason that
he was going to lobby for it to be in a
car
well one of my favorite stories that he
told when he he's been on the show
multiple times
tai and one of the favorite stories that
he told that is on our youtube
uh archives was getting the role of al
bundy
and he yeah and and that that his way
uh uh that everybody who auditioned for
the role played it
big played it big sort of like jackie
gleason
honeymooners type and he right
he had an uncle he said that was totally
resigned but would
that that everything would go be going
crazy in the house and the house would
be falling down and he would just look
and say yeah
what's for dinner and he said that
that's the way he played it smaller and
less
you know and and and and took it in the
other direction and they're like that's
our guy
that's how he got you know that's that's
kind of that's kind of part of the
genius of ed
is that um you know he can throw away a
joke
better than anybody i've ever known and
and
and it's something that you can try to
do you know you can try to
imitate that and and it definitely
serves you really well to go to play to
underplay a joke
a lot of times but there's nobody who
can do it like him
um he he would just
putting once again putting the least
amount of effort into the line
made it 10 times funnier and that's kind
of his
his genius well you've got a lot of that
too ty burrell
tyberrell here on the rich eisen show
before we get to duncanville i want to
keep pulling on this because and i
mentioned this the last time you're on
the show i might do it every time that
you come on here ty
is a video you did for funny or die the
old funny or die
right called the rant writer where
writers
where you were you played a writer
who was hired by athletes and coaches
to write the rants for them like you you
you made it seem like every rant from we
are who they thought they were from
dennis green to practice by alan iverson
to mike tyson saying some of the most
unmentionable things
that you made it seem like you were the
writer behind all that and they were
just
acting out your your words and your
spirit
and that is one of the funniest sports
related
videos i have ever seen i
you know i we had so much fun making
those and we did make a second one
that you know because you can't really
keep up with all the ram
like like that i feel like you know
we're overdue
because there's conor mcgregor and
you know there's there's just there's
all of these people that
just peeling stuff off like
i i feel like we're way overdue there's
almost too much content
[Laughter]
conor mcgregor would be a perfect one
for that right now
mcgregor's mcgregor is a good one you
know
another one too just in going in the
same way that you can go in the other
direction
is belichick you know with his silences
yes
and with his one word i like that
yeah i like that basically like the the
whole
thing the whole uh rant is is me trying
to really
show restraints yeah that's exactly
saying like
[Music]
yeah just saying one and two word
responses
yeah and this is where you told him to
give the look the roll the eyes
[Laughter]
oh my gosh i love that ty burrell here
on the rich eisen show
so are you fired up about the
acquisition of matthew stafford here
um very much what do you make of that
todd
very much i love that we i mean
uh we we got him a bunch of speed
um i'm super curious about 2-2 at well i
mean
who can't root for a 5-9 165
guy in the nfl um
but yeah i think stafford you know uh i
i didn't really follow the the lions
you know much but you always seem like
yet crazy arm talent
and um the ability to kind of you know
do
you know i think there's we gotta
make sure we're really establishing a
run game so he's not running around all
the time right
like crazy but but um i'm excited about
it
so now how did you first come to love
the rams i mean how far back does your
rams fandom go it goes it goes back to
birth
um uh
i was uh i'm dan pastorini's son
um no um
yeah that's all yours that's all yours
run with it
um no when i was a kid
we lived in oregon my all my relatives
lived in los angeles
and they would send us rams gear as part
of like you know just our way of
keeping in touch with each other so the
gear became symbolic to all these family
members that i loved and didn't get to
see
and so then when they moved to st louis
um it was really no skin off of our back
you know what i mean whereas a lot of
people jumped off the
rams because of feeling betrayed
in l.a um we were in oregon
and it was like well we're still just
going to see them you know back then
like
three times a year on television right
so
so we stayed fans we were really
committed st louis rams fans
and um and then in this weird like
uh you know almost like an
eight-year-old
like boys daydream they
they i was in la shooting modern family
and they moved back to los angeles while
it was there
right and if if if you know
if i wasn't already a narcissist i was
you know pretty sure the world rotated
around me when the rams moved back to
the town i was living in
well i mean your co-star uh also
considers the chiefs revolving around
him
from modern family as well so maybe you
caught a little bit of the stone street
move for him
that's all i'm saying they didn't move
for her
and they eric would have thrown himself
on the train tracks before that happened
anyway he would never rule out that yeah
if that was ever you know that's so true
that's for sure
so that is that is great have you been
to sofi
yet have you set foot in that jewel i
have not i have not we're i'm i'm
commuting from utah
nowadays of all places um so
i'm not in la a ton at the moment so are
you giving
are you are you giving me the scoop that
the rams are moving to utah now
is that what you're saying coming here
next they're coming here next because
that's what they do
right wherever i move i'll move to
modesto
and they're coming to modesto that's
really weird how they do that but um
look uh but uh now that the world is
sort of
you know uh the earth seems to be sort
of rotating again
i'm very excited to get down there and
there's
nothing like a time i'm serious it's
like looking if really
if you've ever if you've ever looked
into uh
virtual reality vr goggles for anything
yeah that's what this is you're like
you're watching a game in a vr
goggle it is the sight lines and no
matter where you are
up top down below the translucent roof
that by the way is not attached to the
stadium so i'll give you a heads up that
it does get cold in there
um i mean it is it is i've never seen
anything like it
ever it's unreal it's that it's that it
is
worldly huh well i mean also compared to
no offense
you know where they've been playing last
couple years too you know like to go
from
right you know where where you know
calvin coolidge probably once brought in
the olympic torch you know
to this you know uh it's it's unreal
it's truly unbelievable i'm really so
excited you should be so excited
you should be so yeah so you planning to
go to some games this year or
it depends on yeah for sure okay i
definitely will i think
i think uh you know i i get accused of
being overly optimistic all the time
my my brother gives me crap about that
but i i think every one of my teams is
always going to win
the championship in whatever sport it is
every year i mean you know
also i think this is the home of uh
justin herbert as well
ty so i mean you know so you always i
know the other guy
in that building too here's a little bit
of a secret okay which i don't know if
i'm
allowed to do this but by the way sounds
like you're it sounds like this sounds
like a character from
a modern family where you're putting
your hand next to your mouth and you're
telling yourself
yeah this is this is straight to camera
okay this is what i'm about to say
this is directly the camera um
when the rams aren't on i do watch the
chargers because i'm such a herbert fan
why not
and i think i'm supposed to not watch
the chargers because
we're sort of supposed to be rivals now
but um
but i i i cannot help but watch i love
that kid so
much he is such an amazing person
too um and just
crazy talented um i can't wait to see
what happens in his career
it's amazing it's he is and has been
um towards the end of last year and
certainly in this whole
draft season in a town evaluation season
in free agent season
he is the shorthand of the
new unicorn in the nfl that everybody
right that he is the new short like can
the guy be like herbert
is basically what you're hearing about
so what do you think
why do you think there were doubts about
him
great question what's your take on why
he dropped because there's always
not even that even drop down no no no i
know that like why would miami go with
two
over him because two they also two miami
tour had miami at hello like literally
were
talked that miami was infatuated with
him the minute that he stepped on the
field in that national championship game
for alabama
um and then borrow burrow through i mean
geez
the guy threw 60 touchdowns and won the
heisman in the national championship
so you put all that together and you
know it's not in a vacuum
but um but everybody's got red flags
when they come out of college it's a
it's a nitpicking business
but his red flags seem to be that he was
you know they felt like maybe he was too
humble
in a way like too too quiet in the
huddle
or they weren't sure he could be a true
a leader in that way which
i felt like man you really are to your
point like that is really nitpicking
because
everything else that you see and all of
his on paper and everything is just
amazing
and and his teammates in college thought
he was a great leader
and even the crazy thing is two ties
that he didn't start the season the way
he got a start is because the backup you
know had a
uh you know had a terrible mishap happen
right right right before kickoff the
coach even said
you know uh that that he wasn't the
starter after almost damn near beating
mahomes
without knowing until five seconds
before he had to do
that right and then and then and then
when it all comes down to it
the chargers wanted brady first and you
can't blame him and they might not have
ever
drafted him but it's the way it all
works out in the world man
it's unreal right it really is he
i'm so happy to see him taking advantage
of it
he's just he's incredible ty burrell
before i let you go let's talk about
duncanville season two
of this animated comedy um premiered
this past weekend with two episodes
um i i is this the version of ed o'neill
likes doing everything in the car that
you don't have to be on camera here did
you get to do it
really yeah and it really is next time
i'm in a live action show i'm just going
to ask is there any reason this
can't be animated because
it really is it is it is um i might as
well be
in there in a robe with coffee it is so
it's such a delightful way to work and
if you're
if you're sort of you know a
professional idiot like i am
you you just there's nothing better than
going in and
and making stupid voices for two or
three hours twice a week
um it really is like in some
demented way it just makes me so happy
but this show is really
it's really um funny and populated with
super talented people it's
it's um mike and julie scully and he he
you know was with the simpsons for years
and years and
amy poehler who is sort of you know
without peer in my opinion in terms of
just being brilliant and she
she plays both the mom and duncan in the
show
and she's sort of ridiculous you know as
we all know just ridiculously talented
and
an equally nice person and um it has
that feeling of uh
in my opinion of being sort of like a
great joke machine in the way that
this the simpsons is
um just like if especially during the
pandemic both
making it and watching it uh it is one
of those just great
uh escapes at least it was making it i
hope it is for people watching it is
just
you know it's it's a lot of hard hard
laughs
and how close are you to this soul patch
wearing classic rock obsessed plumber
with the you know what it's funny when i
first when they
when i they heard that description i
heard it as
a classic comma rock obsessed
yes comma plumber and i was like
for i'm just dumb enough that for like
20 seconds i was like are plumbers like
really into geology
[Laughter]
wait is this a thing that i don't know
about
um and then i was like oh right uh i uh
i'm probably further i'm much further
away from this character than i was from
philadelphia this guy is like
super hyper emotional
he's like you got a hair trigger temper
he's
barely he's just hanging on that's like
he's just
every episode is him just hanging on uh
emotionally just trying to either either
the depths of sadness or the like the
height of ecstasy
he's he's all over the map and he he was
raised
gerald mccraney plays my dad in the
second episode he's
just you know he's amazing um but he
gives you an idea of why
that my character's name is jack jack
it's just all he's trying to do is just
be a better
dad than his dad was and um gerald
mcrane is in the second episode giving
us
you know living proof as to why jack
is what he is because zero macrane is
sort of this great santini of a dad
who's
you know it's just brutal he's so funny
in it um
but he's he's pretty brutal to jack so
it's
it's a fun ride man i mean the dads that
your your character gets and and
everything you do jared mccraney in this
one and fred willard before i mean
you're
they're oh my god oh my gosh yeah i mean
so lucky
how about that fred fred's you know
i'll say this over and over again but
fred had the most influence in my
comic point of view of anybody
um alive and i think there are a lot of
a lot of
you know comic actors that were
influenced by
fred through all of the christopher
guest stuff and i mean there was nobody
nobody better at playing good nature i
mean he kind of invented
that good-natured oblivious guy or at
least he perfected it
well waiting for guffman is perfect for
that where he where he asks if the
he should strike the stool from from the
uh
from the set where he's just trying out
for the role
uh in some local theater i mean just
and he's so proud that he knows the term
strikes
[Laughter]
oh gosh it's so good ty thanks for the
call i really appreciate uh the time and
um you and everything and your sense of
humor and and certainly when you come on
the show it
it delights uh i appreciate it let's do
this more often if you're up for it
i i would love that thanks roots it's
always a pleasure man absolutely plus i
need to know where you are so i know
where the rams are moving
so i need to be yeah yeah i'll keep you
okay i'll send you a
gps point please do that please do that
tag me as they say
check out again new episodes of
duncanville on mondays at 9 30 p.m
eastern on fox thanks for the call ty
thanks paul that's ty burrell everybody
right here on the rich eisen show oh man
that was funny funny funny
funny funny funny hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here